con nuestra primera invitada del día
vamos a hablar del presente el futuro de
la guerra en Ucrania un conflicto que
deja miles de muertos y que no parece
estar próximo a apaciguarse hoy por hoy
el foco de los combates está nuevamente
en el este de ese país en torno a la
localidad de Soledad el kremlin y sigue
cambiando el mando de sus tropas por lo
que podría avecinarse una nueva
estrategia de combate saludamos Entonces
en este momento a Susana mangana y es
profesora investigadora del instituto de
derechos humanos de la Universidad
deusto de Bilbao Gracias Susana por
estar con nosotros esta mañana de jueves
en directo América de Francia 24 Feliz
año 2023 Susana hablemos de la situación
actual de Soledad objetivos rusos en
esta localidad Y por qué se enfoca aquí
en este momento
muy feliz año y próspero año nuevo
también para todos tus televidentes Raúl
Bueno lo primero que hay que comentar es
que evidentemente el parón que han
significado las vacaciones de Navidad en
todo el mundo también La tregua
anunciada por Putin para esta tregua
navideña que ambos países tanto Ucrania
como Rusia se acusan mutuamente Rusia
acusa a Ucrania de no haberle permitido
ejercitar esa tregua mientras que
Ucrania acusa al kremming de haber
violado La tregua todos los combates hoy
se intensifican en esa parte del este
como tú decías del río nieper porque
evidentemente es un lugar geoestratégico
para ambos países pero sobre todo para
Rusia que no ha tenido victorias
significativas en las últimas semanas en
territorio ucraniano y por tanto es un
territorio donde además existen túneles
que para las fuerzas para la cúpula
militar rusa son importantes lo que aquí
cabría destacar entonces Raúl es qué va
a pasar ahora que se han terminado las
vacaciones de Navidad que las potencias
europeas pero también Estados Unidos
vuelven a renegociar su Alianza y su
ayuda militar estratégica hace lens
claro Susana de lo que acabas de decir y
saco dos preguntas no para pues
conversar en la mañana de hoy primero el
cambio de de mando En las tropas rusas
de de surquina gerasimov y también
Susana un invierno que no ha sido tan
duro como se esperaba Cómo afecta esto
también el curso de la guerra qué
podemos ver con este invierno que no ha
sido tan frío
efectivamente Bueno lo primero que hay
que destacar es que es difícil sacar una
bola de cristal y hacer una prospectiva
y decir esto es el escenario este va a
ser el escenario más plausible hay que
entender que hay un hartazgo en ambos
bandos hay un desgaste tanto en Rusia
como en Ucrania Ucrania ha tenido
victorias militares significativas por
eso también es que el kremming se ha
dispuesto ahora a cambiar al mandos
militares pero también a de alguna
manera cambiar de alguna forma su
estrategia militar porque no está
consiguiendo las victorias militares que
tanto anunció Putin desde el principio
de la guerra la contienda ya va a durar
el próximo mes se cumplirá un año de
guerra con lo cual aquí lo que tenemos
que hablar Raúl más que de escenarios
posibles son de las fuerzas motrices de
los drivers que sí podemos vigilar en
esta guerra para saber cómo van
cambiando Y de esa manera poder hacer
esa prospectiva que tú me estás pidiendo
Ahora lo más posible o lo más plausible
en este primer semestre del año 2023 que
ahora comienza es perfilar Cómo está la
política interna en Rusia lo que vemos
es que hay un una radicalización de las
élites rusas que están apoyando a Putin
quien se mantiene firme al frente de la
federación eso no creo que vaya a
cambiar en este primer semestre del año
por lo menos Putin va a seguir
gobernando en Rusia lo que ocurre Es que
le van a exigir cada vez más acciones
que vayan en la línea de la escalada
horizontal del conflicto qué quiero
decir con esto que Rusia muy
probablemente va a tener que pasar a
otro tipo de acciones en la zona gris de
países que no pertenecen a la otan como
para Seguir generando temores
incertidumbre inquietudes en la otan por
ejemplo en países como Georgia moldavia
que siguen siendo
de parte de la Esfera moscovita que eran
territorio de la unión soviética como
recordarás hace algunos años por otro
lado también no creo que en este primer
semestre se vaya una escalada vertical
esa sería otra fuerza motriz otro Driver
las cada vertical implicaría el recurso
a la utilización de un arma nuclear
tácita por ahora yo creo que Rusia no va
a recurrir a ello porque sería forzar
una actuación de la otan y de la Unión
Europea o de alguna manera eso se puede
dar solamente cuando Rusia vea que hay
una derrota humillante para sus fuerzas
lo que creo que podemos avecinar ahora o
avizorar en el primer semestre es un
estancamiento del conflicto Por qué
Porque se esperaba que ese conflicto
estaba estancado por el invierno que no
ha sido tal como tú dices pero que con
la llegada de la primavera muy
probablemente se van a recrudecer los
combates y lo que va a haber es un
desgaste Muy cierto de ambos de ambos
frentes militares por ahora Ucrania está
teniendo esa ventaja significativa sobre
las tropas rusas porque Recibe un
armamento y adiestramiento en cantidad y
calidad suficiente pero suficiente para
mantener el conflicto no para vencer a
Putin y recuperar todo el territorio de
ucra liberarlo de la presencia rusa que
es la posición maximalista de zelenski
que por otra parte ya te voy sí Raúl
decirte que esto es lo que aburre a las
lo que está cansando a las potencias
occidentales es esa posición maximalista
de zelenski que no sea viene a negociar
con Rusia el fin de la guerra Susana
hablabas de la primavera clave también
Ucrania posiblemente teme que haya un
ataque a gran escala en esta Primavera
cuando se vaya ya un poco más a el
invierno también un actor importante en
toda esta guerra es el comienzo también
lo ha sido belarus Hay posibilidades de
que Rusia vuelva nuevamente a atacar por
belarus entrar a Ucrania por el lado de
la luz
Bueno yo lo que creo Es que Bielorrusia
siempre ha sido un Aliado fuerte ya de
antes del conflicto y ahora con
lucachenko al frente de biela Rusia es
un Aliado sólido además muy dependiente
él para permanecer en el poder frente a
bien a Rusia lo que podríamos ver es que
Putin utiliza biela Rusia justamente
para abrir un nuevo frente de esta
guerra y aliviar así la presión en el
este lógicamente que puede recurrir no
solo a la artillería como está
utilizando ahora Bielorrusia en este
conflicto sino que como digo biela Rusia
puede convertirse en esa pieza clave
para aliviar y sobre todo para generar
todavía mayor incertidumbre como decía
antes esto sería parte de ese Driver que
yo llamo la escalada horizontal del
conflicto Raúl Susana estamos lejos de
ver una posibilidad de diálogo a lo
mejor no un diálogo digamos para salir
completamente esta guerra para terminar
completamente la guerra pero si algún
tipo de concesiones Vladimir Putin en
estas últimas semanas ha hablado entre
líneas también de ese diálogo pero no se
esa disposición en el terreno qué crees
que pueda pasar con el diálogo
bueno justamente como tú dices esto
tiene que ver con la política interna de
Rusia ahora Putin ya lleva ya unas
cuantas semanas antes de terminar el año
2022 y ahora también iniciando este año
nuevo diciendo que está dispuesto a
negociar pero que es la otra parte la
que no quiere y ciertamente se le esquí
todavía se muestra firme sólido al
frente de las tropas en Ucrania porque
ha conseguido esa esas victorias
ucranianas y por tanto ha conseguido
convencer a sus aliados occidentales de
que tiene que continuar suministrando
armamento en cantidad y calidad
suficiente pero como yo te decía antes
hay hartazgo en las sociedades europeas
porque también la guerra el conflicto
armado ha repercutido en el precio de la
energía estamos aquí en invierno un
invierno que no está siendo demasiado
crudo por lo menos no en el sur donde me
encuentro en Portugal en España en
Italia ciertamente que no pero
claramente hay un hartazgo de la
sociedad todo conflicto conlleva un
desgaste también ante la opinión pública
y por tanto Los líderes europeos muy
probablemente estén presionando
a celenski y eran para la primavera
condicionar el suministro de ayuda
militar siempre y cuando zelenski
abandone esa posición maximalista que
todavía mantiene hoy día es decir No
creo que pueda recuperar Por supuesto
que crimea no está en discusión Por más
que zelenski lo anuncie pero muy
probablemente celensky Quiere toda el
territorio del don más Y va a tener que
conformarse con territorios al este del
nieper es decir que Putin abandone la
pretensión de aquellas zonas que declaró
como
independientes y que se anexionó en el
2022 que tenga que devolverlas a Ucrania
pero yo creo que esto va a depender muy
mucho de Qué actitud adopte a partir de
ahora tanto la otan como sobre todo las
cancillerías europeas que son las que
están suministrando ese armamento que le
ha permitido hacer lensky estas
victorias militares en el campo de
batalla y precisamente quería
profundizar en ese tema Susana el apoyo
armamentístico de la otan también de los
países europeos y de Estados Unidos
digamos que
limitado hasta cuando estos países van a
seguir aportándole a Ucrania porque como
lo dices tú también tienen que atender
pues cuestiones internas evidentemente
esta guerra también les representa un
gasto enorme a todos estos países
entonces también la población sobre todo
en Estados Unidos digamos el ala
republicana también está diciendo ya a
Joe biden basta con tanto apoyo a la
guerra en Ucrania económicamente
hablando no
ciertamente y también vemos que hay
algunas brechas Por qué Porque Rusia
también intentó una estrategia que muy
poco se habla de ello Raúl y me gustaría
apuntar contigo aquí mínimamente hacia
la misma Rusia intentó generar un flujo
constante de refugiados tanto de África
como de oriente medio que pudieran
llegar a Europa para desestabilizar a
Europa todavía más como producto de este
conflicto lo que vemos que es que esa
cantidad de refugiados que llegan de
Países Árabes países musulmanes sobre
todo africanos no ha llegado en el
volumen en el flujo constante que
pretendía el kremlin los que llegan son
producto también de la crisis
alimentaria del cambio climático que se
producen esos países Claro que hay
dependencia del trigo de los cereales
que se importaban en túnez en Egipto
desde Ucrania y de Rusia pero perdón
desde Sí desde ambos países en la
contienda Pero esto no ha generado ese
flujo masivo de refugiados que de alguna
manera desestabiliza a la Unión Europea
lo que sí hay es un hartazgo de las
sociedades europeas que entienden que
este conflicto demasiado que se está
invirtiendo demasiado en armamento y se
habla muy poco de diálogo con lo cual yo
creo que la Unión Europea finalmente va
a ir condicionando la entrega y el
suministro de esas ayudas militares hace
el esquí a que cambie de posición de que
abandone esa posición máxima lista y que
pueda sentarse a una mesa de negociación
sobre todo ahora que se ve que Rusia ha
permitido que tanto telensky como la
Unión Europea cruce de algunas líneas
rojas sin que haya desencadenado en la
escalada vertical del conflicto a qué me
refiero con esto que no ha utilizado
ningún arma nuclear como tanto se bregó
al principio por segabrof suministro de
asuntos exteriores recordarás el año
pasado Cuando decía que había líneas
Rojas se han cruzado algunas de esas
líneas rojas y no escalado verticalmente
el conflicto no quiere decir que esto no
ocurra como te dije antes un escenario
plausible sería si Rusia prevé que va a
haber una derrota humillante para ellos
en el frente de batalla podría recorrer
a utilizar armas nucleares para entonces
forzar el fin de la guerra pero por
ahora está apostando a incrementar el
suministro de su apoyo por ejemplo
municiones que vengan tanto de Corea del
Norte Como de China subrepticiamente si
se quiere pero sobre todo no contar solo
ya con drones de Irán sino también con
misiles balísticos eso sería una
posibilidad en este primer semestre del
año 2023